is black and white so so listen to this
and this is why I say women love love
the streets so much because because you
have a man that's prepared to to marry
you he's prepared to literally take you
on as his wife all the things you've
been talking about for the last 10 years
you haven't had and the simple thing it
says is you've got an X that used to
blow your back out I don't want him
around you no more like no no but this
is how men think you want me to talk
about how this is how we think we think
some okay this is how some men think but
the types of men you are attracted to
think like that because if not you would
have picked one of these guys in your
comments on your DMs for years I've won
it uh nasty that's desperate I would
never see you you're doing it again you
haven't given them a chance because
these are the guys you do you don't see
you don't see these guys but the guys
you do see are the ones that speak like
this and think like this I'm being
honest with you and if you want to look
at it look at it as this is new
information you've never heard before
take it in those new information
unless you're willing to go for the guys
which you'd never look at these are the
guys which will let you have him as a
friend because they've been trying to
try to take you out for years and they
want to see you the types of guys that
meet you and it and they speak like me
they would never allow him to be your
friend they'll just say look that's your
boy you can if you see him that's cool
but all of that stuff cuts off now that
I'm involved I think the bigger issue is
that he might be cool with it he might
not but the whole point is that his girl
won't listen to him facts that's the big
problem right there as far as I'm
concerned you know he might be called he
might meet the guy and say yeah you know
I respect your relationship but if he
turns around and says I'm not
comfortable with it and the girlfriend
turns around and says she's not going to
listen to him she doesn't respect him
and she doesn't value the relationship
enough you know that's that's the
message the moment a girl says that to
me bro I can't lie like yeah she's
single man yeah so what you are saying
yeah basically that if your girl said
that she had a friend that is an exp but
she would like to bring him around you
though you would feel some type of way
because me personally if my girl that
I'm seeing said that she has a friend
and she doesn't mind bringing me around
him then it's like it proves to me that
there's not really nothing to hide what
it proves question because like you're
around me 24 like me I like my girl to
be around me 24 7. so if she now then
brings the that's they're not there I'm
not expecting them to be close because
me and I don't speak every single day
and I'm falling in a 24 7. that's how
you're making it seem no but you're
fighting for it like you do that if this
is just a thing so for example if you
guys were friends and you might
occasionally bump into each other and
you know you know maybe a family
barbecue or something we don't even have
to have this conversation but the
conversation you guys are giving me is
the one where you know what you know we
played in the sandpit together we dated
for this we up our family's Too Close
you know that's my I'm like hold on a
second why did you get with him then and
just fix it like I don't know what I'm
here for that's really sad it's not sad
it is because why can't it be a thing
where I respect his mum enough to call
her auntie and go over for some jollof
and and have a good time with the family
because I don't have my mum in the
picture but you have a man who you're
supposed to be building that
relationship with and that's still fine
I believe in him and I and I will
definitely go through that Journey but
to think I'm disrespecting my husband
because I'm friends with a man but I
think that it's not that you're friends
with a man the point is you're not
listening to him like again love to men
is respect it's saying you know what I
might not agree with this but I respect
your judgment so I'm gonna go with it
I'm gonna do what you say but like men
don't want an argumentative woman and
what you're doing is why would you're
not listening to me you keep trying to
say but but you're actually not
listening to me men and women are
fundamentally different we look at
cheating differently by the way you're
acting and what you're saying to me we
classify that as cheating you know no
but you have to listen to it you don't
have to I'm listening so I just don't
agree so it seems like I'm not listening
no but you don't see not agreeing is
that part where you're going to kick
back men are not going to change and the
types of men that will allow you to do
this you do not check for you don't look
at you see past the invisible to you so
the types of men that will allow this to
happen you do not check for so what I'm
saying as a man and what this other
gentleman is saying as a man is that if
you if we're taking all my misses and
I'm serious about you yeah and I want to
introduce you to my family I want to
marry you if you cannot do something
like this to go into the then it's fine
but this is why I say more than women
offer them streets and they want to stay
in the streets because when you've got a
man that is all you want to show is that
a bit of commitment from you you're like
no no no no no the Rave is so important
I'm going out my girls are so important
my man but that seems that seem or a bit
far-fetched because nobody said I'm
going out no matter what you said or I'm
gonna go and see him but it's when we
asked you the question if when we we
asked you if he said this what would you
do yeah and you said no I would still do
what I'm gonna do okay no I that's
that's not agreeable that's that's not
feminine that's argumentative okay
and I like you I think I think you know
what it is you you remind me of a lot of
women that I've met and I've dealt with
and like you looked apart so I'm saying
I look the part what do you mean by that
what do you mean you're very you look
very feminine okay yeah you look very
feminine in your you know I mean you're
made well you presented very well so you
look very feminine and when you talk you
have a nice tone of voice but when we
say certain things as soon as we say I
get to see your eyes start rolling back
and you want to kick back with it but
but what are you really kicking back for
like um do you know what I've never
heard these point of views and it's good
to be open about these kind of
conversations I do how old are your
brothers they are 24.
um they're twins shout out to twin
brothers so have you ever spoke your
brothers about relationships yeah and
what do they say they have their
different twins we're sisters yeah they
have
um are you guys are sisters yeah oh
there's a horse
I was wondering I was like oh they must
have been friends for a while she's my
sister I guess they have their own
different views on relationships but
when you say what what do they think
what do you mean by that like obviously
okay so you're there you're the oldest
yeah older sister so obviously they're
slightly um they're slightly Junior to
you you're still quite young so a lot of
the times is
brothers would would speak to their
sisters but they're the young and
they're younger so obviously so you're
older them my thing is this I don't know
obviously your relationship with your
fault like I don't know any of those
types of stuff but I tend to think that
a lot of times girls I've had friends
that are man and they turn they speak to
them at least one or two guys will be
real and be like yo this is what it is
like like so when you have a real guy
that's real then he should be saying to
you everything I'm saying is it's not
some it's not some fallacy it's not some
idea that that I've just just created
essentially create out my my head a lot
of men will lie as you said they're not
going to care about body count you know
why because they're not going to be
around long enough to care about it
they're going to run it up and give it
to your husband he's the one that's
going to care about it so when Mana when
you're saying oh I've never heard this
before is because why would they say it
men never speak about so how are you
women supposed to learn about it if you
don't see it
because okay more men need to tell the
truth that's that's really what it is
and there should be a father in the home
but a lot of like women weren't raised
by wives and they don't have a dad in
the home so they have no one to teach
them I was I'm not saying you I'm sorry
sorry I don't know anyone's backstory
here but I'm just saying in general like
your dads are supposed to teach you this
stuff
okay
and your brothers I mean I don't have
all the same views as her so so what so
so your sisters um so what do you think
um I I kind of agree with what you're
saying but only because I know the
relationship like the friendship between
them I would understand why it would be
hard for her to just like kick him to
the side for a man who possibly could be
gone one day whereas he's probably never
going to live her life and also just to
say if the guy did have a problem with
me being in a situation I would be happy
taking a step back yeah but they're
saying you're not good no bro you're not
the problem no it's not yours yeah I'll
be disrespectful I hear that yeah yeah
like so yeah it's not you it just comes
down to um comes down to the to the
woman's decision and the willingness to
get like put that aside for to make him
happening I'll be honest a lot of times
men don't we don't even kiss
oh sorry A lot of times man we don't
even care we just want to know you would
do it we just ask you and then soon your
first answer is the answer that lets us
know and when we start kicking back it's
like it's like if you're gonna wear
something out I love the fact that my
girl's gonna send me what she's wearing
now I can pick or do you think do you
think this is too much too much skin if
I say that she's gonna change it not
because not because I'm trying to stop
her from wearing something no I'm just
like oh maybe that was a little bit you
know I'm trying to say like you're
giving a bit too much of what you should
have been giving all right cool you know
what I'm saying yeah
um and maybe we'd like to be a part of
the process we're not stopping you we
see you can go out but when you start
going out too much or if you start going
out with single friends or potentially
you're going to places where you know
maybe the vibe isn't right or what
they've heard they claiming drama or
things have happened in the past that's
when we get worried you know I'm trying
to say to you but we're not trying to
stop a woman from ever going out but
we'll get concerned when you start going
up too much and you put yourself in
situations where men can start hitting
up to you and then there's alcohol
flowing and and and you know whenever
people say I made a mistake or I was
drunk that's never happened when someone
wasn't drunk and they didn't make a
mistake so you have to take a lot of
these scenarios out and we know women
cheat as much as men do so there has to
be someone doing the cheating and if we
talk about women having women are the
ones with the gateway gateway sorry The
Gatekeepers the sex then once you add in
nightclub what you're adding out with a
single whole friends watch out once
you're adding alcohol once you add in
all of these other factors and the fact
that you can make a mistake well human
how about we just try to just take away
some of these factors that's all I'm
saying
respectfully
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible